so ben as you know is a world-renowned
expert on the crimes committed by the
premier rouge uh he's the a whitney
griswold professor of history and
founding director of the genocide
studies program here at yale he's the
author of the classics how pol pot came
to power the pol pot regime blood and
soil genocide and resistance in
southeast asia and the important recent
book vietnam
a history from earliest times to the
present um
i think one of the most important
distinctions that ben has is if you want
to get his books for cheap you just go
to family lau in saigon and they're all
mimeographed and available in really
expert reproductions right so i'm sorry
yale university press but
it's kind of a mark of having made it in
the world when people are bootlegging
your books i think i haven't reached
that thing yet but i'm looking forward
to some day learning from ben how to get
that done anyhow and eve zucker is a
visiting has been a visiting professor
in anthropology here at yale she's a
member of the steering committee for the
yale genocide studies program and
current president of the center for
khmer studies her books include forests
of struggle moralities of remembrance
and upland cambodia mass violence and
memory in the digital age and
coexistence in the aftermath of mass
violence and of course the book we'll be
talking about today as well
it's not always the case that historians
and anthropologists collaborate well but
this is a really exciting example where
the convergence of an important topic
has brought together ben and eve and
also many of our students here at yale
and other scholars around the world to
come together for this important book so
and i want to say one last thing
is this book is the result
of a conference and workshop put on here
at yale in november of 2018 so i just
want to thank them for bringing so many
important people to do work on this
topic here so please join me in
welcoming ben kiermann and eve zucker to
talk about the book
we would like to thank eric harness and
chris musker and the council of
southeast asian studies
and all of you for being here today both
online and in person which is pretty
exciting um
and we also would like to thank the
contributors to
the book who are some of whom are here
today but not all of them
uh who made this project what it is
so um i'm just going to go move over to
start the powerpoint
and i'm going to
write
[Music]
so uh what is the book um the book
is a
thematic and historical examination of
the causes and consequences
of violence in southeast asia
particularly between the periods of 1945
up to 2020 when the book was published
and covers six cases
cambodia thailand indonesia myanmar the
philippines and vietnam
and as you can see here we had 18
contributing authors to uh to the volume
which are listed here there's quite a
few of them so we thought we'd just list
them for you um
and we'll be talking a little bit more
about the book but i just want to move
ahead a little bit
now um to the next
to to talk about how the book started
so
this project really started from a few
different a few different reasons one of
them was that ben has been teaching
courses on southeast asia forever
maybe not foreign
for a long time and uh and i was
teaching courses on southeast asia and
particularly on violence in southeast
asia and one of the things that we
noticed uh
sorry can everyone understand me online
is it clear
okay
so
one of the things that we noticed was
that there's not a lot of anthologies
that cover
violence
of the region in southeast asia
the ones that do exist many of are like
10 years old or so
um and a lot of them aren't specifically
about mass violence some focus just on
the cold war which that's a fairly
recent one but other ones also focus on
terrorism like the one by damien
kingsbury
um
and there's some good ones but they're
but they you know they often only
included a few countries so we thought
there was a need for something for
something that covered
the region as a whole on this subject
um
so that was one thing another thing that
we notice is that there's a lot of new
scholarship going on and not only new
scholarship with new scholars and young
and upcoming scholars but also
very new topics that really haven't been
covered
before in the past and that was really
exciting so that was another impetus for
for the project
um and the other major thing that was
going on at the time which
i'll go over in a little more detail in
just a minute uh was what was going on
in the world at the time if we
think about it it's it's a little
different now but back in 2018
as crazy as it is now um it was pretty
crazy then
so you know you have this
authoritarianism on the rise you have
populism on the rise and this was pretty
much all over the world
um
you know we had trump you had putin uh z
and so forth um but in southeast asia
you also had the same thing
happening particularly
uh with duterte and the philippines
and also hansen um
and there was also a lot of
impunity of leaders they were pretty
much doing what they wanted wanted with
no consequences
at the time and a lot of intolerance or
difference different ideas different
types of people and
so forth so
uh sort of to zoom in a little bit and
to get a snapshot of that
we see that during that period you had
in myanmar the
rohingya genocide taking place which had
been going ongoing since 2016.
you also had
the
tens of thousands of rohingya being
murdered
you know in their
in their villages
which are being burned and uh there's
mass executions and so forth
and by
2018 there were also
uh 730 000
refugees already in bangladesh who were
fleeing for their lives a lot of them
were also fleeing not to bangladesh but
also out on boats and so forth
to malaysia but it was a real crisis
taking place
um the crisis continues
but it it was pretty severe then as well
um
you had mass imprisonments into
concentration camps of the rohingya
and uh finally in august of 2018
you had the unhcr declared that the
generals of
the army should actually be held
accountable
for genocide so that was myanmar a
little bit about it
um
in thailand uh you had a
two coups over
a very short time um
you had demonstrations taking place
which had been ongoing for a while you
had again you see impunity of the
leaders
there's violence in the south
there's violence against political
opponents
there's surveillance happening online
facebook
also though people didn't feel safe in
other places about what they said there
was numerous arrests and
um
sometimes for as long as up to 10 years
for for for crimes like saying something
about the monarchy
um
turning now to cambodia
you had the national election that took
place that year in july and that was
another
volatile situation you had a lot of um
discomfort at the time uh amongst the
population who
feared that
um there were people they were being
surveyed um even in coffee shops
there were surveillance also online and
there were good reasons for them to be
worried because in 2016
uh the activist kem camille was
um
was assassinated
and then you also had the opposition
leader before right before the elections
uh kim soka he was arrested
um and several other
members of the opposition were not
allowed to participate in elections
also in cambodia that same year you had
case
o2 happening
um of the khmer rouge tribunal that was
with
nuancia
and kusampan
and on november of that year which was
actually a week after our conference
the ecc found nuancia guilty of genocide
against both the ethnic chams and the
vietnamese and kusamhan
guilty of genocide against the
vietnamese and both guilty of
crimes against humanity including
of extermination
so that was it was a huge
deal uh
at the time that they actually passed
down those sentences of genocide and
also those crimes against humanity
in the philippines the war on drugs
continued and showed no sign of letting
up in fact duterte stated that he had no
intentions
of um
slowing that down or stopping it um
you had the same year you had duterte
pull out of the international criminal
court the iecc
in a blatant you know
statement of disregard for
any of its principles um
and that was a year also maria ressa who
recently won the nobel prize
who is also the founder of the um
of the
news outlet uh rappler
she was arrested also during that time
okay and so with all of that happening
in that just
in that one year that was the context
where we decided to have the conference
um and that was what it was on
everybody's mind when we had the
conference was this keen awareness of of
the
the atmosphere um
uh in the world and what was happening
and so the keynote for that conference
we had jeffrey robinson
who spoke about indonesia that was on
the first evening
we had um
24 participants in all
representing um several different
countries
and we also at the end we had
uh
l mccoy gave a wonderful um
talk at the end which wrapped up the all
the
papers and he provided some great
insights into how the different pieces
um come together
and that was on the last day
um and we appreciate
the support of course that we got from
the council of southeast asian studies
and the yale genocide studies program
and um
and other
other
parts of the l macmillan center and so
forth um for
for
providing us sponsorship
for that conference and also of course
the new york southeast asia network
which was our primary funder for that
event
so um so with this this conference was
really the
basis for the volume
and it was the papers that came out of
it that were presented
uh on that day
so just
going now for a moment um
to
the context of where our book starts
um
and that would be just in the post-world
war two like immediate post world war ii
so in 1945 on august 6th
you had a the aircraft u.s aircraft a
b-29 dropped the atomic bomb
onto hiroshima thereby ending the war
and also um
basically signaling the start of the
cold war and new world order and so this
ends up having immense consequences for
southeast asia
and the world but in southeast asia
because it meant the japanese withdrawal
from southeast asia
and so the end of all the brutality
uh
that they brought with them to southeast
asia but it also left a little bit of a
vacuum there for a brief period of time
the colonial powers were gone
um some of them would end up coming back
but there was an opportunity there for
things to change and for things to
happen it was one of those chaotic
periods that al albert alfred lau called
a meltdown
so that was the context
and um
so uh
what happened then so there was this
opportunity for independence
that was that was there
and with that opportunity for
independence then nations had to start
imagining what type of nation would they
want to have and so now there were these
different
systems and different ideologies that
they could draw influence from
potentially there was communism coming
from
china and the soviet union and you had
also american
capitalism which provided another
thought form of thinking and form of
organization
um so this was this is a context and i'm
going to stop
right there and turn it over to ben
who's going to talk about the
connections the historical connections
between these different countries and
then later we'll come back and i'll talk
about some of the themes
thank you very much
i'd also like to thank the council on
southeast asia studies
excuse me as well as the macmillan
center
and
the genocide studies program
and the
orville shell center at the law school
for their support for this uh project
which has um
been a pleasure to work with eve
on uh the final book project as well as
as the conference as eve said she zoomed
in on the actual events of 2018 where
the when the conference was held and the
actual coverage of the
various uh topics in the book i'd like
to zoom back out again temporarily just
for a while
and look at uh not so much at the
content of the book but the
context of the events that we cover in
the book
the much larger context looking back at
the early modern period in southeast
asia
and some of the big themes
of violence in southeast asia as well as
the chronological context
and the thematic as not just thematic
but chronological and the causation of
mass violence in southeast asia
i recently had an exchange in prince
with yehuda bauer the eminent historian
of the holocaust in which he looked back
at his work over
many many decades
on the holocaust and he thought about
the presence of the jewish people in
europe
and
the importance maybe he thought about
the importance of the issue of migration
in as a long-term
issue in the history of the fate of the
jewish people
and i thought about that in
our discussions
and what
can that tell us about the history of
mass violence in southeast asia because
southeast asia unlike china and india is
a predominantly maritime world region
like mediterranean europe an asian
mediterranean perhaps
comprising large archipelagos and long
coastlines
and as many of you know leading
historians of the southeast asian region
consider southeast asia to be a
crossroads
anthony reed subtitled his 2015 history
of southeast asia
critical cost crossroads
in his 1971 book vietnam and the chinese
model
alexander woodside wrote quote if
mainland southeast asia was a crossroads
of civilizations
the europe of asia he puts that in
quotes
in its juxtaposition of competing
cultures and societies
traditional vietnam was a crossroad
within this crossroad
especially after it had seized the
mekong delta
the sum of all the political
difficulties he concludes and the
cultural tensions was tremendous unquote
now southeast asia's earliest documented
cases of genocide involved ethnic groups
migrating along the coasts or from the
interior to the coast or encountering
new religious movements arriving in the
region by sea
along the eastern coast of mainland
southeast asia the vietnamese southward
expansion and the genocide of charms in
1471
to 1509
were followed by cambodian massacres of
ethnic vietnamese who had subsequently
migrated down the coast into the mekong
delta
french missionaries reported that a
cambodian attack on the vietnamese
controlled port of hartian
in 1731 had quote made an enormous
carnage of them they counted more than
10 000 of them lost
afterwards
they killed all those vietnamese that
they found in cambodia men women and
children
then in 1750 cambodia's monarch gave
orders or permission that the
missionaries wrote to massacre all the
vietnamese who could be found and this
order was executed very precisely and
very cruelly this massacre lasted a
month and a half only about 20 women and
children were spared the massacre was
general from cajon to hartin
the vietnamese kingdom in turn resorted
to similar measures in the 1830s when it
conducted systematic massacres of
cambodians in attempt to colonize their
country
in southeast asia's western mainland
bermans expanded south to the coast
then the home of the hmong people
in 1740
mons killed seven thousand bermans in a
genocidal massacre in the port of syria
in 1757
conquering burman forces massacred
thousands of months in their port of
pegu
and then on the island of java in 1648
the ruler of the kingdom of mataram
slaughtered 5 000 islamic teachers and
members of their families
now despite sharing some common
geohistorical features like migration
these cases nevertheless proved to be
scattered
relatively infrequent outbreaks over
five centuries of southeast asian
history
otherwise i think it's still true to say
the region is indeed a cosmopolitan
crossroads of civilizations remarkable
for harboring nearly all the world
religions buddhism hinduism
islam christianity and confucianism are
all prominent in southeast asia
so we have
a major theme of migration perhaps that
underlies
outbreaks of mass violence but these
are not really connected to one another
they're scattered outbreaks over a long
period of time but there are some
perhaps big themes
what we have by contrast
in the cases
that we look at in these in this book in
the post 1945 period
are much closer connections
between the cases
not just big themes but
closely related
cases
and that's what i want to look at now to
zoom back in at the cases that that we
cover in particularly in the in the
post-war period
uh katie manion from the shell center
formerly of the shell center for
international human rights and the law
school has a very interesting chapter on
intent
as a element of genocide she starts off
with a legal explanation of what intent
means as
component of genocide not just general
intent meaning the action must be
deliberate not accidental
but also specific intent
meaning the
importance that the action must be done
in order to destroy a group as such
it must be carried out
consciously desiring the
destruction of the group as such that's
very important with genocide not
necessarily with crimes against humanity
such as extermination or even other mass
mass violence or even let alone
political violence which we also cover
but she does say that
these
cases of
intent can be seen
from a distance and they can be charged
as coming
from
by a non-judicial observers and she
points out that in a number of these
cases intent was pretty clear
even though
it was not
accurate to stay
from a distance or while the cases were
taking place
that
the perpetrators were already criminally
liable because they hadn't been judged
by a court but a non-judicial
authority or observer or
ngo studying these events could
state that the intent
was observable and could have said much
earlier than they did
that there was a case for genocide let
alone other
examples of crimes against humanity like
extermination or political violence and
she's critical i think quite accurately
of many of the observers for being
hesitant in pointing out where there was
a case for an investigation or a
criminal trial which would decide
whether or not these perpetrators were
criminally liable and this is one
feature i think of these cases that were
um
that connect a number of the cases that
we look at that there was a delay
in the suppression or the intervention
in in these cases in southeast asia i'll
just give you one example of where i
think there could have been much quicker
uh recognition
of the possible intent
eve has mentioned nuhu and shia and
kusamhan who were found guilty in 2018
of genocide in cambodia and nuache was
found guilty of the genocide of the
charm muslim minority
in cambodia
uh the pole pope regime of which he was
the number two
uh was
in power from 1975 to 1979
the only foreign head of state to visit
cambodia during that period when the
pulpit regime was in power was naywin
the military dictator of burma
he visited
in november 1977
just after pol pot's triumphant visit to
china in which he came out as the real
leader of the
democratic campaign of the pulpit regime
he had just returned back to cambodia
triumphantly
he uh
didn't meet with no win
publicly we don't know whether they
actually met privately
but nae when the only foreign head of
state to visit democratic campaign in
the four years it was in power
he met
four times with new and cheer he met
four times with cusampon the two
officials the head of state of cambodia
cusable
if he didn't meet with pol pot perhaps
pop pot was too busy unlacking his
suitcases after coming back from china
he probably had a lot of now suits that
he had to unpack but
he met four times with newer cheer and
four times with you some pot if you
didn't meet secretly with pop pod i'll
be a monkey's uncle but at any rate the
genocide of the charm muslims was well
underway and knew and she was later
found guilty of it
new and cheer in november 1977 returned
to burma
and in february of 1978 just weeks later
a couple of months later
operation nagamin
which was a massive
discrimination and persecution of the
rohingya muslims the first of its kind
in burma
by may of 1978
250 000 i believe
rohingyas had fled into burma and into
bangladesh
and uh
many of them had been
killed while they were fleeing by the
no wind military dictatorship if nain
had not discussed
with
nuancia and gives up on the persecution
of the charm muslims in cambodia just
weeks before again i'll be a monkey's
uncle in the four meetings that he had
with new chief
then again of course
in 1991 and 92 a second campaign began
in burma
of
persecution of the
rohingya muslims and then two more waves
ending in genocide in 2018
but it wasn't
until much later
that foreign observers
began to call for
investigation of genocide against the
rohingyas in burma decades later really
the
katie munion has this
all documented how hesitant
international
observers were
to uh
identify
this as an ongoing
potential genocide there was talk of
ethnic cleansing which is not
an international crime
but it gained recognition in the in the
balkan case uh in the in the 1990s
there were all kinds of other terms
applied to what was happening to the
rohingyas but it had happened to the
charm muslims in the 1970s and they win
had visited cambodia and gone back to
burma to implement something
that turned out to be very similar so
there's a connection that i don't think
has been uh detected or certainly not
enough made of it between these two
cases that we cover uh in this book
um
thailand
was never colonized by
the
western powers in
southeast asia it was the only country
like ethiopia and africa it was the only
country in southeast asia that was not
colonized however it didn't escape the
post-war violence as eve has pointed out
that the other countries of southeast
asia were subjected to
indeed thailand was drawn deeply into
the
massive waves of post-war violence that
affected southeast asia
three-quarters of the
bombing raids over north vietnam were
by planes that took off from air bases
in thailand
and this had something to do with
violence within thailand as well as the
former foreign minister of china and
tanaka
later complained
the civilians like himself a foreign
foreign minister
he said didn't even know
that
the thai military were building these
new bases in thailand it was only later
they found out that the united states
bases that were used for the bombing of
north vietnam were being built the
civilians
although in the government in the
cabinet were not informed
uh thailand also sent 25 battalions of
special forces to participate in the
secret war in laos
so thailand was drawn in to these
international
campaigns
of violence that it had managed to
escape in the colonial period before
1945.
another example of the connections is a
country that managed to keep out the war
under the reign of prince cinnamon in
cambodia uh was prince cena's he managed
to do that partly with the uh by his
alliance with china uh he maintained a
neutral foreign policy for cambodia
during the 1960s and he saw china as a
mentor or a or a
a
figure a power that guaranteed his
neutrality in the cold war he visited
china in october of 1965 for its
national day october 1st
what he didn't know
was when he went to pay homage to china
pol pot was there on at the same day on
the same day secretly visiting china
pogba
the
secret head of the communist party of
campuccia the underground
opposition to prince edward the chinese
and pot himself kept this secret
from prince ciao not the head of state
of cambodia
the two cambodians were there but only
potpot knew that the other party sienna
was there
now what else happened on october 1st
1965
the coup in indonesia
which was also covered by jeffrey
robinson's uh opening chapter in our
book
what was important for cambodia was the
mass slaughter of the indonesian
communist party
that began on that day october 1st
china's national day
by
accident i'm sure but the uh the
importance of it was as pol pot later
said uh in 1977 in a uh retrospective
history of the communist movement in
canada
if we had been
in that position the same position of
the communists in indonesia that is an
unarmed
relatively peaceful communist movement
we would have been in greater danger
than the communists in indonesia but we
weren't we decided that we wouldn't do
that we would stage a rebellion against
sydnook's regime which they later did
having looked they were looking at the
communist
disastrous
experience in indonesia on october 1st
and afterwards in 1965.
and so the pope decided that he wouldn't
he wasn't going to put himself in danger
of what happened to the communists in
indonesia instead he was going to do
that
exactly to his opponents in cambodia
which he did when he came to power in
1975.
another example of the connections
between the southeast asian countries
that we
uh cover in in this book that the
contributors cover
very well i think is the
connections
between
countries that are not usually linked
malaya
the philippines and south vietnam now
these connections exist
uh
political connections but they also show
how different
these countries are
the philippines
was became independent in 1946
but it
uh
was immediately
uh
struck by
an agrarian communist revolution or
revolt by the hook agrarian
rebels
and
it took place in central luzon
and one of the
people who took part in the successful
defeat of that rebellion
as an adviser to president magsaysay was
edward lansdale colonel edward lansdale
who helped design
with mike's isa's reforms some agrarian
reforms
that
managed to undercut the appeal of the
hooked rebels in central luzon and bring
that rebellion to an end
later when the
insurgency in south vietnam gathered
force landsdale was transferred to south
vietnam and took a position as an
advisor to president noeden siem of
southern south vietnam and became an
important i think he opened the second
there were two cia stations
in south vietnam
in 1954
meanwhile in
malaya the
british had held on unlike in the
americans in the philippines held on to
their colony
as in malaya as late as 1957 there have
been a similar
malayan communist party rebellion from
1948
and the british had fought that
rebellion in what was called the
emergency the malayan emergency
and one of the british advisers military
advisers who uh
helped the british put down the
emergency the milan communist party
revolt
was uh
what was his name
forgotten his
name right now but it was um
it was a
a
key figure in the um
uh british successful counter insurgency
he was later transferred
sorry i think the last name was thompson
he's part of an article
so robert thompson was later transferred
to um south vietnam at the uh advice of
uh coach rahman the prime minister of
malaya after independence in 1957
and he was
then
made such an impression on node in cm
that siem asked the british government
to send him back to south vietnam
as head of the british military advisory
mission
and he uh went back to south vietnam and
according to
the
cia george khan the cia's head george
carver so robert thompson and golden cm
together devised the uh
strategic hamlet program in south
vietnam
now they've been very successful the
british in malaya in undercutting the
insurgency there and the americans and
maxis have been very successful in
undercutting the insurgency in the
philippines with
those two experiences were successful
but in south vietnam
they weren't the strategic hamlets were
a failure the uh nlf or viet cong
insurgency uh grew larger and larger and
eventually was uh nearly successful in
1965 at the time the americans
intervened with ground troops in 1965
why was that
not the case like it was in in the
philippines and malaya because south
vietnam is a very different society than
those two countries the insurgency was
quite circumscribed in both malaya and
the philippines regionalized or
ethnically circumscribed in malaya
whereas in south vietnam
land uh
inequalities were great not only in the
mekong delta but also
along the southern and central
vietnamese coast and the strategic
hamlet had program had to be much larger
and more
unpopular
and eventually failed so south vietnam
was quite a different society than the
philippines or malaya so the although
the connections existed between those
countries and the strategies that were
adopted were quite similar
they failed in south vietnam because of
the different
different societies there
there is also a difference
in
the countries that uh experience
violence
after world war ii and those that didn't
uh
burma and indonesia for instance
particularly in the 1950s
uh experienced
a democratic uh flourishing
in the 1950s
under socano in indonesia and under unu
in burma
despite the challenge of a korean revolt
and the communist revolt in burma both
starting in 1948. uh burma was a
successful democracy until the overthrow
by the military under nae win in 1962.
similarly indonesia was a multi-party
democracy
until around 1958 when sukano
instituted what he called guided
democracy which shaded into the
military takeover in 1965.
but those two examples in the 1950s show
that southeast asia its largest country
on the mainland at least geographically
was burma and in indonesia the largest
country in southeast asia did have the
experience of
at least temporarily successful
democracy and those um
that is now the case once again after a
long
uh suharto era
ending in 1998 so we do have some
examples of heterogeneity of diversity
and of the
variety of possibilities that are
in the history of post-war
southeast asia
finally i'd like to mention uh the
chapter by huang min vu
on cambodia which uh
is
a nice way to sum up what i'm saying
because it's a hard-hitting attack
on all of the parties to the cambodian
uh
disaster uh all of the uh
international
global responses to
uh the genocide in cambodia come in for
a fierce criticism on the part of
it's worth reading i think
because he is uh unstinting in his
critique of vietnam of asean of the
united states of china and
he ends with a kicker i'm not going to
tell you what it is but i suggest that
you read to the end of this chapter
but i'll leave the rest to you to finish
thank you thank you ben that's really
very interesting as always um so um i'm
gonna talk so ben talked about some of
the historical connections and i'm gonna
just go through probably fairly quickly
some of the
um conceptual thematic connections um so
how long do we actually have here
we should
end by one so we can make sure there's
time for q a okay so i will probably go
in somewhere in depth and then some will
go more quickly
okay
so uh there
is sort of two sets of conceptual themes
that are sort of show up immediately at
the beginning of the book and one of
them's in the well they're both actually
in the introduction
but one uh but somebody who's looking at
the book might notice that that the way
things are organized in the table of
contents are a bit different than
they're discussed earlier on in the
chapters and there's reason there's a
reason for that
these chapters can be organized in a
multitude of ways and can be thought of
in a multitude of ways and that's really
part of the goal of the book is that
people can look at the different
chapters the different cases and
understand connections between them
historical connections regional
connections
and other thematic connections and
hopefully it's a it's
useful then
for students and also for people
teaching about southeast asia or mass
violence
so uh we wanted to just draw out some of
those themes that may not
all together be
obvious um somewhere obvious somewhere a
little bit less so
so um
here are some initial themes to consider
and i'll discuss
uh at least a couple of them in
a little more depth uh so there's social
and political transformation
during periods of change and during
periods of
transformation as i'll discuss in a
moment
it it's a very vulnerable time a
potentially very dangerous time
there's this
ambiguity ambiguity of identities
ambiguities of intent
also liminality marginality people who
live in marginal places who occupy
marginal places within society or
literally on the
border or whose identities for some
reason are seen as uncertain
there's the political imagination
which is not something that's always
considered but
how people imagine
the other how people imagine nations how
people imagine who other people are
this all comes into play during these
periods
i mentioned earlier the impunity of
leaders
and the role of leaders and then
talked quite a bit about that as well um
and uh
there's also the the haunting of the
past and the present which tends to be
sort of the
enduring um
the during not only consequences but
shadow of of genocides and mass violence
that continues to haunt societies in
various ways and then
just briefly the
which
i'll talk about in a moment killing as
both as a technical procedure on the one
hand
which is very different than another
type of killing that takes place
that's much more visceral and and you
see that in different cases and it's a
really sort of interesting question of
why that is so and how are they the same
and how are they different and that's it
really i think actually an area to be
explored in far more depth than it has
been
so um
social and political transformation as
um as ben mentioned he talked about how
um in some southeast asian societies um
like it's in in indonesia uh they went
from democracy
to then when suharto comes in
and massacres
massacres
hundreds of thousands of people a
million people or so
um how
that's been
happening within this transition from
democracy into a dictatorship
and and then you have other situations
whereas you have in
burma where with the move from democracy
during that transition you have the
violence perpetrated against the
rohingya now it's interesting in
southeast asia
and thinking about south that is from
coming from an anthropological point of
view here um when
you think about in southeast asia about
transitions about transformations
in life cycle rituals they're in life
cycle
when during pregnancy during birth
during death
it's considered a very fruitful and yet
very delicate process great care must be
taken because there's a danger in this
process of when something
is moving from one state to another when
something's coming into being
and i think it's a useful way of
thinking about these periods also
transitions of moving towards
independence or changing of political
systems and so forth it's it's
it's people there's an uncertainty there
there's a vulnerability there there's a
danger there and in this sort of context
you end up with situations where
um
people feel insecure and then they often
you know in some cases as we saw in
in burma and so forth the
they end up finding
people that both that identifying people
as
imposters and
ibrahim uh sorry azim ibrahim talks
about this notion of the imposter
and the outsider but so does
elliot frost freeman and andrew aung who
talk about exclusion
and inclusion within the state and this
theme you see comes up
quite a lot certainly through all the
myanmar readings but also
certainly in cambodia where you had
coastal path
and tron lung talking about the
ethnic vietnamese during the long period
who
were seen as
in some cases as demons and as the enemy
and as essentially masking
their true intent which the intention
connects up with um catherine munion's
chapter
so i'm looking and i'm seeing three
minutes left i'll just quickly go
through
the slides so at least you can see
where some of the chapters sit
with some of these uh different themes
so with the ambiguity and liminality i
discuss in a bit it's obviously very
connected to the
theme of transformation and transition
but one of the things that happens in
these contexts
and
arjuna pottery talks about this as well
in terms of ethnic violence is that
there's
there's this language that starts
occurring at the language of the
imposter in these contexts of violence
and this um counterfeit
person somehow and counterfeit
identities and and that plays out and
you see this like an al mccoy's chapter
uh where he talks about duterte you have
this situation where he the people being
targeted are the marginal
community of of what are the so-called
drug users and and dealers who are being
picked out as as you know
not as in this case excluding as
as um
as eliot prosperib and anderon talk
about they're some of the people that
are pushed out excluded from
society then
um
you also have the topics of the theme of
impunity
silence and role of the leaders
while silence and impunity are obviously
linked
they also can be treated separately
um
well silence certainly contributes to
impunity
it's it's also rests on its own and
impunity has other sources as well um
several of the old chapters talk about
impunity particularly though in tyrell
haberkorn's chapter
in on uh thailand and also in
hawakka ponds chapter also thailand and
also in laura mcgrew's chapter who talks
about the
uh talks about cambodia in the post
war in the 90s 2000s era
and the amount of impunity the
government has had
there with with violence that's been uh
perpetrated since the khmer rouge
by the state um
okay um
just quickly uh just sure this one
technical versus
visceral violence um
so in
by technical violence what's meant here
is violence that's
very much removed from the person for
example the the aerial bombings that
sophie quinn judge talks about in her
chapter in vietnam by the us
or the aerial bombings by the by uh in
vietnam
uh during the first indo-chinese war
talked about in christian lenses chapter
in daniel baltman's chapter which is the
takes place in the prison and torture
center of tulslang it's a very kind of
different type of technical violence
there it's
the body is very much involved but not
involved
in the kind of intimate way with the
visceral violence instead the bodies are
treated as mere resources
so they're they're harvested for blood
they're harvested for a while the
gallbladders are removed all to sort of
serve the purposes of the
revolution of the khmer rouge
um
purpose
um and so there you have it's very
clinical so there's these medical
experiments on the one hand but on the
other hand it's kind of like factory
farming
in a sense on the other that the bodies
are just simply recently
processed
um visceral several chapters cover that
um
and let's see since we're out of time
there is the political imagination which
i mentioned a little bit
earlier and this has to do with occurs
in several chapters of how people are
imagining themselves as citizens
or how they imagine citizenship
altogether
how the nation is imagined allah and
anderson
comes in here and
also
in terms of the
the other
um i won't
the haunting of the present in the past
i'll just say trump lungs chapter really
uh really goes into this into some depth
a really fascinating chapter
which talks about the massacre of the
vietnamese in the early 70s under lognol
which was in these killings were
propagated by the government
and
she shows a juxtaposition between on the
one hand um this soccer hotel on
the riverways in phenom pen reflecting
on the shimmering surface of the water
there
uh the osaka hotel is owned by a
vietnamese tycoon and that's contrasted
with underneath the water so still the
bodies of the hundreds of thousands of
vietnamese victims that were killed in
the 1970s that continue to haunt
today
um and now with continued ethnic
ethnic tensions and uh racism against
the vietnamese living in cambodia
we can see how that haunting
how that haunting sits beside that
so we are out of time so that is the
organization of the book and the
chapters um
um and
just to end we would like to end with
uh
in memory of um benny woodyono who gave
the first talk of the
conference actually and unfortunately he
passed away
just a couple months after that he would
have loved to have been here many of you
have met him and knew him
and um
he in many ways encapsulated
this whole period
that we've been talking about
he was born and
and raised in indonesia
and he was ethnic chinese he was
persecuted for being ethnic chinese as
was his wife francesca who's in the
middle photo there
he later joined the u.n he was the
governor of siem reap for the u.n
for untech
and later became the special
representative um
for cambodia of the u.n to cambodia
during those years and that's him
and that we can't see um in the picture
but he's standing there with um
with king narada sienna and
his and queen monique
and um
barry is giving one of his
his lectures so
we wanted to
take this moment to remember him
so i know 10 minutes left thank you all
very much
for this wonderful talk so what we're
going to do is open it up to q a since
we have some people on zoom i'm going to
carry the microphone if you have a
question just so they'll be able to hear
it properly and then i'll run it back to
them so
bear with me for that little time delay
and also i want to say to people who are
on zoom if you have any questions put
them in the chat
um and al will flag me and we'll read
the question out loud
and so we'll get started any questions
in the audience
thank you and uh thank you both for uh
for
the book and for the presentation
my question um
excuse me now something that that comes
out of me listening to the the parallels
that you both uh spoke of is the clear
and obvious role that uh that communist
parties whether as insurgencies or as as
political oppositions played and i
wonder if you can speak to
is there a common or parallel origin of
these of these movements or what were
they were they trained in
uh in china is the chinese communist
party uh during the chinese revolution
uh were they similarly inspired was it
was it uh training in europe or
was it you know each
each
country has a sort of different
route a different route of communist
opposition and insurgency
i'm going to let you have this fun
please
i think that there is um
a variety of different kinds of
political inspiration for the many
different
uh
and diverse kinds of
political and mass violence that we
cover um i think you know some of the
most extreme cases
uh range from the communist party of
campaign
in the pop-pop regime
uh to the military dictatorship in
indonesia under suharto you know which
was an anti-communist
uh purge of of of communists uh
mass murder of communists uh there are
cases in between
which
perhaps are exemplified by the burmese
military dictatorship which was
inspired by
socialism in one country i think they
call themselves the burmese road to
socialism but it was definitely a
military dictatorship and was opposed by
the different branches of
the communist party in burma and and and
and definitely repressed that
the uh
there are you know a number of different
factions of
southeast asian communism um
that uh
took a number of different roads that
the malayan communist party
uh was very pro-china the vietnamese
communist party was more independent of
china
there is a a
common
chronological theme in 1948 when many of
the communist parties
rose up in rebellion from indonesia to
the
to
burma to malaya
and that was often
thought to have
come from a meeting in calcutta in 1948
and and
uh it was alleged that uh soviet
instructions uh or common turn
instructions led to many of the
southeast asian communist parties
staging rebellions at the same time
but there's not consensus on
that
regional complicity or regional
coordination
amongst historians about that i've seen
historians um debunk that that theory
although the
uh
historical or chronological uh
uh
concatenation seems pretty convincing
um
but i i think what strikes me more is
the
is the uh
across the board
violence that uh is characteristic of
the cold war in southeast asia you know
other people might disagree but it seems
to me that there is you know looking
looking at the violence in places like
thailand burma
vietnam both north and south
indonesia
the philippines malaysia malaysia
and also the appearance in all of those
places or nearly all of them of of
democratic potential
one case that struck me
just reading
this morning was the
in brunei which we don't cover in this
book
the
elections that were held in 1962 for
some
some
only partially democratic uh
participation there was you know the
british was still
called the colonial power there was the
monarch the sultan of brunei but
elections were held as for
representative government
in on a partial level
and uh the
people's party brew and i won all 16
seats
it was you know a a landslide
by the by
representing the popular vote and now
they weren't going to get what they
wanted they did they didn't get
either
full political power or what they wanted
was
not to be included in malaysia
and uh and so they
chose
the most disastrous option which was to
revolt
uh and they staged a violent uh revolt
and were crushed by by the british and
brunei is still
a
monarchical dictatorship
so
where do we where do we go with that
information
what ideological inspiration do you
attribute that to
it seems that there is a
wide range of
possibilities in southeast asia
we have a question in the chat um so
i'll take that first um to in the spirit
of inclusion and i'm gonna read it
because it's difficult for others to see
from the back of the room
um
the story ben kiernan told about
linkages between violence in cambodia
and burma including the possibility of
meetings between pol pot and nae nguyen
was absolutely fascinating i wonder if
you could explain on the dilemma expand
on the dilemma these types of cases
present for historians on the one hand
the circumstantial evidence is too great
to ignore monkey's uncle
on the other hand historians tend not to
prize circumstantial evidence and the
availability of archival records is
challenging and patchy at the best times
how then should historians seek to
uncover and understand the hidden circus
circuitry that linked cases of mass
violence and that's from matthias
fibinger
yes it's quite true that i can't prove
that uh pol pot met with no win
maybe one day we can check this
i don't think it's
going to be
documented it would possibly be
documented by now in the cambodian
records it might be documentable in the
burmese records
if it if it occurred
i just think
that it's likely
that i could be proven wrong
um at any rate
four meetings between new and chia and
they win
uh with nuancia
uh having been convicted of genocide
against the charm muslims and they win
starting off a campaign a few months
later of mass persecution of burma's
muslims seems to me to be
likely that they discussed their
common interests uh in at least one of
those four meetings uh whether that
would
uh
lead you to conclude that there is a
linkage between the two cases
both of which ended up in genocide
in countries that were otherwise
unlinked
is
is of course something that ought to be
explored and which is what i'm saying
that's the reference to the monkey's
uncle but i think that uh
catherine munion is quite right in her
chapter that
there were opportunities missed
by
observers of the burmese case
to
point out
the strong likelihood
of of
this
rohingya genocide
eventually
not necessarily just
on the basis of no wins visit to
cambodia but
on the point she makes about intent
and the
evidence
that
existed
over decades of persecution of the
rohingya
that non-judicial organizations as she
puts it
could have called for investigation
into
whether a genocide is ongoing or likely
earlier than they did and i think she's
right about that
you know i think your hand does it
maybe you could also tell everyone who
you are since it's the first time to be
in person
thank you
my name is
and i'm a
current postdoctoral associate in the
council of associations that is so very
exciting fun to be here in person with
everyone
so one thing that i really appreciate is
the connections this precisely that
called you have pointed out
despite the diversity of the region
now what i'm interested in is the
opposite in the sense that now given
these common commonalities
you haven't had just read the book but
clearly the many episodes of mass
violence that the book has
covered there is a range in terms of
um
perhaps degree of violence
causes violence um
how violence perpetrated and so forth so
the example you gave instant is the
khmer rouge killing of
um
the degree of violence there is for
instance certainly not the same as
perhaps of violence occurring under the
hub rebellion in the philippines right
so there's a range there so i'm
interested in from your perspective your
understanding
what might be the possible factors that
explain why in some cases
that can be
perhaps more
or sort of more uh fact that the prevent
violence from escalating for instance to
the experience like the killing my
religion and so forth
so what explain a variation
in contrast in the coming hours thank
you
thank you for your wonderful question
and um it's it's really an excellent
point there is clearly a very large
range in the various different cases
covered in in the books and cases also
beyond the book
in terms of degree and scale and causes
and so forth and you know that's one of
the things with taking on a big topic of
political violence in southeast asia for
it in across really different regions
and not even all exactly in the same
time period that there are lots of
different factors um
both in terms of global factors of the
global politics that are going on and
also in terms of local politics and
local cultural
uh local culture as well um
i think that you know
apart from the large thematic
commonalities for example the cold war
you had
uh for example aerial bombing in in in
cambodia and you had aerial bombing in
laos and and vietnam
uh
as well
you still had though within that same
cold war you didn't have that saint
while it played out
in other parts of the region for example
in indonesia
uh there was no aerial bombing there why
well for one thing there was not an
external
source that's that's coming in with
these airplanes doing the the bombing
even though there was also bombing
you know within those countries as well
the type of
violence and the types of
targets that was happening was different
in indonesia
mass killings in both cases
but um
they weren't trying to um
some of the aims of the regime itself
and the idol ideologies of the regimes
were quite different
and there was of course external
players in the indonesian case as well
for example you have the british as it's
been in all the headlines
recently
um
you know through the the release of the
various documents
that have been released um that talk
about their part in that there was
certainly the u.s
role to play there but it was secretive
in that case where it was over or
in um
in vietnam so i i think that it's it's a
very large question that you ask and
there's lots of different differences
even in cases that may happen at the
same time or even with some of the same
players
but um
yeah i think it's that's
i'll stop there because
it's a big question
we're going to take one last question
for the sake of time and i see that
kuiha has a question
thank you very much for your um
uh book and your fascinating
presentation my name is
i am also a pastor from um southeast
asian studies council on association
studies i have a really quick question
um basic based on what you have
presented and new question um i'm
wondering about the methodologies
about you know across the chapters and
authors applying
when they write about
their case studies
because i think ben mentioned that there
are some case that is un observable and
i believe that there is many cases
um you know in terms of the documents
the recording he says something is
missing there and then
when we and then you also highlight the
cases here in south asian countries so
i'm wondering like which method
matters good work and in this particular
cases
and in this particular area compared to
you know when they do you know holocaust
for example or they do you know
other
mass violence in other places and then
how
the area would speak something more
particularly
in in the way that you conduct um you i
mean authors conduct the
their research
okay
i'll be brief
the the collection and the volume is by
um
it's not only different countries but
it's also the the authors of the various
chapters are coming from different
disciplines so they're using different
uh
uh approaches to to do the research
sometimes with
what
although they overlapped quite a bit as
well but uh but there is inner you know
interviews um some rely more on
interviews somewhere on archival
documents
and um
but it does to some extent depend on the
country and what's available in terms of
the archives either and what's
who it's possible to interview
and that also is a factor of time if
it's if it's something that occurred
a while ago those people
may not be directly available to
interview where if it's something fairly
recent you can take either there might
be more interviews but less archival
resources
so i'm just going to um
and add on to that
i think one of the gaps that that i
think we
could have filled uh but didn't was was
east timor you know i think that's one
of the major cases of mass violence that
that
that we didn't cover
but there are others as well we just
obviously couldn't cover
everything
but
on the
different question of
why some cases of mass violence occur
and others don't and why some are more
some regimes or
parties or individuals are more
restrained than others i come back to
the question of long-term causes
of mass violence or genocide and the and
the immediate ones you know some leaders
or parties or
institutions or leaders of institutions
do make decisions that are
going to escalate violence jeffrey
robinson talks about this in his chapter
quite
illuminatingly you know he's that that
it
it's not just the ethnic conflict or
these uh you know clash of civilizations
that samuel hunted to put it
or the
fact of you know migration or
war poverty ethnic economic
destabilization these long-term factors
can exist but for a major
crisis to turn into
a genocide or extermination or other
crimes against humanity it still
requires
a decision
by a group of perpetrators
to take advantage of that opportunity to
enforce or impose
a campaign of mass murder and some
leaders don't
do that
they refrain from doing it
and i think they might
commit violence they may
repress
opposition parties they may put people
in jail that they may not commit
mass violence
others do and we've seen that across the
spectrum
that does happen
but in some cases it doesn't happen and
i think
to look at the immediate causes of
genocide we have to look at political
decision-making
and sometimes that's informed by
ideology and sometimes it's informed by
uh
political
or human decisions that
uh relate to the nature of the
personality or the
group around the person
or the or the group of people who
decided to kill a lot of people rather
than
accept
less power
i think that's an important factor as
well the immediate
causes of mass murder
it's
political decisions
i just want to say thank you to ben and
eve for a fascinating discussion a
wonderful way to start our return to
hybrid normalcy if there's such a thing
as hybrid normalcy um
and remember next week we have elena
leslie who will in some ways carry on
the conversation into the present day so
really great continuity so thanks
everyone